[Music]
in regretful robbery news mm-hmm
submitted by Cindy from Boston my face
hi Cindy UFC fighter poliana viana oh I
heard about that now I've got a man who
attended to mugger in Brazil she [ __ ]
rear naked choke em and said let's wait
for the police so this is poliana this
is Luther I wish someone recorded a man
I know look at her belly buttons even
muscular she has a a bit her [ __ ]
runner the [ __ ] muscle is tight yeah
yeah real tight little veins and biceps
on it yeah like like if you put a finger
in it it [ __ ] guillotines it and it
chokes your finger out right it's so
tight if you pops it looks like angel or
pasta oh the shoes waiting for it uber
outside we have uber in Brazil yes he's
waiting over outside her apartment
complex and that's when a man approached
her she says like he must have been
really sneaky because she didn't notice
his presence until she was really close
and she was on the phone and so as soon
as she noticed him she started putting
her phone away
ah she's waste and then um that's when
he told her give me your phone set the
guy give me your money or following give
me your phone
don't try to react because I'm armed
then he put his hand over a gun but then
she realized that it was too soft so she
was like okay he's really close to me if
it's a gun he won't have time to dry it
so that's when she stood up she threw
two punches and a kick and he fell and
they
caught him in a rear-naked choke him
down and she said all right now we'll
wait for the police
yes so just three strikes two punches
and a kick because the picture of his
face now classy now you can see I think
it's because he fell that's him that's
him happen in the Octagon
oh my God look at him bad wait is he
doing a shocker
yes yeah punches oh my God look at him
look at him was it a kick to the face we
could question the [ __ ] face do
that's her right yeah do you up see dude
this guy's skinny man skinny dude yeah
why would she choose the buffest woman
on earth no that's what I'm saying like
why would you do that it already says
what she does for a living I know yeah
look at her shoulders she looks like she
looks pretty fit yeah he picked the
wrong girl no context clues yeah yeah
I'm kind of glad he picked through those
yeah if it's the CVS is like oh she
works at the store yeah but you have
seen of a girl in Brazil also
manhandling a dude she just had yeah
she's punching him in the [ __ ] face
yeah maybe might have that she's [ __ ]
wild and this is the gun that he had
there's just a cardboard pen oh my god
in a rush he was in a rush to rob
somebody because that should just pour
look how tiny it is grab his little
brother's gun yeah just doing this is
more believable I got mugged in South
Africa they tell you about that today
this is probably seven years ago eight
years ago during the day I walk outside
I was with two comedians a guy named
orny Adams and a Canadian fella by the
name of Ian bagg they run across the
street to go to like some store to get
something I walk out and I'm on the
ground and they have their knee on my
back I'm crying like screaming - as soon
as you walk out they grab you and do
through me
the ground and I'm screaming well you're
by yourself there was hundreds of people
around too you know George like that
that's exactly what it sounded like okay
like that right I did that no one helped
you no one helped me oh all my stuff and
I started trembling and crying right and
then the comics came and they start
laughing at me and it was well how did
they did what did they say anything to
you they just [ __ ] took you down in
Haiti where they watched my blackberry I
had a blackberry and and some money and
some money so your community buddies
were just watching you don't go across
the street watching I can see you know
me I'm on the gun sorry I'm sorry anime
Julie I mean there's like tons of people
just walking by you like nothing and
their area and then they then they still
make fun of me were they there when you
got robbed or were they like doing
something in there okay we're watching
me from across the street and every time
I run into them now they go like that in
front of my face I would promise did
they get you at gunpoint what I did a
real checkin up right I do what I did
one but they were already gone they
pointed a gun at you and put you on the
ground no there was no no oh boy they
just threw you on the ground look what
happens to guys okay Devastator we're
checking up her chicken duck is like
this right you put your hand like this
right and this is his head even if you
pull like this sometimes because I'm
gonna sing the first part will you act
were you actually got robbed okay so
there was no weapons involved they just
threw you on the ground okay could I
just say something about your tone right
now do you're looking at me like I don't
know what I'm doing in LA no no I'm
gonna tell you something right now do
accurate I'm in Africa okay
South Africa is still Africa [ __ ] it
was speaking
come on it's like Australia oh really
yes okay so what I'm gonna say something
to you to Girl Scouts three on the floor
what - Girl Scouts three on the phone yo
these true teenager they're black boys
they're black boys hey [ __ ] you guys all
right by the way okay one is 12
yeah I don't know how older they must
have been like maybe let us see 15
apiece right they're saying they were
speaking English
but they were doing that and they're
putting getting my stuff they ran off my
crime happened maybe a minute a minute
[Laughter]
I'm sorry
well I was just because I just you
didn't explain the part or the beginning
part happened so I felt really bad what
do you mean because I mean like it sucks
to get robbed I got robbed by senior
citizens in China so I go that's a more
humiliation hey that's a very
humiliating with the whole village it
was a gang of senior citizens how old
are they
they were like over 60 in a whole
village of them came out and surrounded
me and my buddy and they mugged you well
they told my buddy to pay and they
pulled out a laminated sheet and it was
like you got to pay this amount of money
for the toilet then they started arguing
so it was basically a scam and they're
trying to intimidate us and I looked
over and it felt like a scene from nacho
libre where you know he paid his buddies
to come down and like fight but it was
his farmer buddies so all these people
that were trying to intimidate us and
we're all just standing here like this
is crazy and then I just gave him a few
dollars and then they all went away Wow
I got robbed yes so what are you making
fun of me I'm not making fun of you I
just wanted to know like how it went
down I walked outside during the day was
in like noon right I followed the ground
on purpose or someone pushed you know I
felt first that's where I'm computer
they pushed me to the ground
they tackle me to the ground right all
of a sudden others asphalt
I remember being hot right very hot then
I couldn't get out that's right
and a screaming I look up I see my
friends across the street like Airmen
watching and I'm screaming at the McHale
then they take my stuff they run off
were they scared too or were they
laughing they were a combo is a combo
deal why are you laughing I wasn't gonna
sneeze oh if I saw you I would have back
to him no I
Alice I think that you would have
laughed your head off I would have back
you up hell that was laughing back to
you I believe that Bart would write
David you're on the fence you're a
[ __ ] coward I'll tell you this why
are you insulting someone that just got
back you up tell me friend I had a dream
where she was in it and even in the
dream she got captured
I looked it I said no more I just read I
said she's dead and I ran and I woke up
laughing because it was too realistic in
your dream you didn't dream I left
you're a coward
even in your dreams yes but what I want
to say too is that I want to see CCTV
footage of that event happening because
I know what happened
you tripped and fell and these guys were
on she's trying to help you up and you
just started screaming you okay
[ __ ] no we got no take it I want
to see that see CCTV footage of you
giving it to them and you screaming in
their face [ __ ] but I could be wrong are
you there
it was very traumatic I believe so okay
and I've been mugged a second time too
but that was under a young girl when I
was in Korea I had a watch in these
Street kids always children attacking
you yeah I don't know why because they
know they can take me when they see me
no they were just what do you call it on
the street like gang compass yes and
they are they need me in the stomach the
ground
yeah and they took all right remember I
was like eight nine years old what like
I was walking back to my grandparents
house and it was crying like that you
know if you're walking by yourself
around Korea it was like two blocks away
from my oh yeah yeah yeah if they live
in a rural place yes Uggs
I just traveling so it wasn't a street
gang you with some farm boys these
villains like are here I know keep
making them because your mind it was so
scary that's how it felt like tell the
story it's like yeah but do it can I
just say something okay
it's something about storytelling you
have to exaggerate your circumstances
right and as a friend you have to accept
what I'm saying but that's not what
you're doing I am accepting you I'm just
saying it's better as our boys because
now I just picture this Korean kid with
just a [ __ ] hole in his pants where
it's dick is out here well that's not
what happened and it was a street gang
[Music]
look that sounds nice so if you got a
girl go pop pop pop pop and that's what
they do for the kids we say Bissel
oh that sounds like Jeff Nestle Mexico
Mexican say pesos no beso with the beef
money you're Mexican right yes how do
you say kiss and baesell
I mean okay that's all I learn you know
Papa is cute right yeah yeah
besito besito yeah yeah
[Music]